my favorite closes which i got from  jordan belfort is fair enough sound fair  enough i just love this clothes so much  because it's like fair enough right you  make a concession fair enough so many  times we were like well they made a  concession and i'm a reciprocal human  being it's very hard for me to deny this  request and so yes i do believe it's  fair and then you say boom then let's  move forward someone says that's a lot  and we say no worries what if we did  this fair enough they say well he made a  concession that sounds fair or if we did  this does that sound reasonable that's  not like a fair expectation yes it does  great and then you can go to close the  sale